propose en compagnie de Gilbert le
voyage sans passeport
Gilbert le C nous revient et c'est en
Guinée française que nous allons partir
ensemble je crois que nous attaquons
notre voyage par Conakry n'est-ce pas
oui je suis arrivé
dans cette ville dans l'entrée qui est
un peu la banlieue les toits sont
recouverts de tôle ondulée c'est un peu
la ville de la tendon du lait
moderne
en fer pour les Noirs mais il préfère
vivre dans leur case
dans la vie se fait tout se passe au
grand terre à la toilette il y a si peu
de place dans la case les filets oui il
y a un petit port de pêche à Conakry qui
est fréquenté en principe que par le
noir
dans ses ouvriers ce pêcheur courrier
est un ouvrier syndiqué il sert de ses
doigts de pied pour travailler Julien
alors le poisson qui est pêché est vendu
la plupart du temps sécher
alors il y a un commerce qui se fait sur
toute la surface sur toute la région de
Conakry aux alentours et donc Conakry
même il y a que la femme qui se rend au
marché d'ailleurs elles sont très gai
danse dans un autre sur un soutientes ou
bien le 2 et un soutien
espèce de fardeau
de casserole de vaisselle qui vient
d'Europe
est tenu dans le dos de la mer
par la
qui vend et qui fait l'épicerie dans les
bonbons plus ou moins fendus et des mots
dessus par le commerce de tissu qui est
tenu exclusivement par les Libanais
et les Syriens
alors ces Libanais ont des ouvriers qui
travaillent sur des machines à coudre
pour confectionner les fumées parce que
les noirs sont souvent beaucoup
s'habiller alors on rencontre souvent
des chaussures vernies dans que la
grille
sont assez simples comme montage
alors le marché aux oranges qui est très
important Conakry mais celle-ci ne sont
pas exportées on ne voit pas la couleur
en noir elles ne sont pas orange comme
ici elles sont vertes à moitié vert
souvent même très souvent épluché dans
cette membrane blanche qui les recouvre
encore sèche à l'air et durcit et permet
au noir de manger l'orange en pressant
et aspire le jus
mais elle est aussi bonne que celle le
meilleur même peut-être non que celle-ci
elle est meilleure que celle que nous
trouvons sur nos marchés
j'ai emprunté la route pour rejoindre la
région des Savanes on circule très
facilement en Afrique en faisant de
l'auto-stop on trouve toujours des
Européens qui sont là votre merci si je
puis dire pour vous emmener
et bien aimable à eux et bien comme un
pain
et on ne sait jamais quand on arrive en
partant avec et on attend pas très
longtemps sur la route on fait du stop
au départ ah bon
qui ressemble à notre Verne voyez la
population les foulards dans la pelle se
partent de riches vêtements sont des
colliers de cuir
du fil électrique
ça leur donne très chaud mais cette
région est très vallonnée ça rappelle
l'Auvergne un peu plus sec
il y a des stations climatiques qui
s'installe c'est à 800 mètres d'altitude
et européens au week-end viennent se
détendre pendant deux jours de trois
jours
de changer l'atmosphère
alors nous continuons la piste
c'est de plus en plus sec
et d'où approchons nous arrivons dans la
région de savane chez les cognagis mais
ce village est particulier le sol est
recouvert de sable
sans déjà l'approche de du saharaons
particulières sont faites en vannerie
sont cylindrique avec un chapeau de
paille par-dessus elles ne sont que
poser à même le sol il enregistré
souvent c'est noir c'est cognagui de
déplacer la case de la soulever de la
mettre de 3 mètres plus loin ah bon
c'est comme un paravent en quelque sorte
qu'il pleut assez rarement à part la
saison des pluies malakato qui dure un
mois et c'est une construction c'est de
la vannerie
au soleil avec celle-ci que l'on
fabrique les calebasses elles sont
coupées en deux voyez l'écorce est
séchées
pour elle
alors dans son monotone plutôt un
piétinement
les hommes dansent le soir parce que ça
m'encouragent
mais moi un peu dans mon voyage je me
suis pas à tarder il aurait fallu que
j'attende payer très cher d'ailleurs
pour avoir l'autorisation de filmer
alors je me suis contenté de cette
petite danse de femmes monotone qui
m'ont coûté un billet de 100 francs
simplement évidemment c'est très lent
mais ça s'explique probablement on parle
tout à côté vive les Peuls ce sont des
nomades qui vivent sous la l'abri de
branchage
il vise parmi leurs troupeaux
les femmes très longueur de journée
environ un demi litre de lait
en principe que de ça on se demande même
à cette époque de la sécheresse ce que
les vaches peuvent trouver comme
végétation
ont des tresses qui pendent jusqu'à la
hauteur du monde
toujours dans la même région les basses
arrivent
ils vivent dans des fermes ne vivent pas
en village leur cas sont construites
avec des moellons
on leur fait les petites tresses parce
que les invités vont venir pour aider à
concasser l'arachide ça se passe un peu
comme les battages en France
après le concassage à l'arachide
il y aura une petite fête et des danses
ce sont des fétiches des gris gris
qu'ils appellent pour protéger la santé
du bébé
cette jeune fille s'est taillée les
dents en pointe la mode dans sa vie
qui va servir à nourrir tous les invités
qui vont venir tout à l'heure travailler
les enfants dans la peau beaucoup plus
claire que les parents
font d'ailleurs de jour en jour au bout
d'un mois
là on leur fait déjà des tresses
qui est cuit
le noir mange avec les mains
puis là
c'est plus près quelques invités qui
sont déjà arrivés ils mettent la main à
des femmes qui viennent aider parce que
l'homme ne se prête pas ce travail
l'envirait aucun d'ailleurs pendant
toute cette scène ils apportent un
cadeau chacun apporte un café
c'est non seulement ils viennent aider
pour travailler mais en plus ils amènent
un cadeau ça c'est le l'arachide qui est
pilé
tout à l'heure on attend que le soleil
on attend que le soleil descend d'un peu
à l'horizon parce qu'il fait très chaud
et on ne travaille pas en pleine
après-midi
alors la racine est mis dans un mortier
et tout le monde se met à l'entoure pour
piler
tout le monde fait ce travail en cœur en
chantant
il s'agit de séparer la graine de
l'écorce
bah justement non la graine n'est
pas rayon va très bien on tamise le tout
pour séparer les corps qui est
complètement réduites en poussière avec
la graine
sera pilée par la suite et donnera la
farine que l'on a vu apporter un cadeau
tout à l'heure que l'on voit à droite
dans ce travail dure assez tard le soir
alors les plus âgés voyez ce que le
battements
ils sont très gains
en question
et tout le temps très heureuse que je la
fais et maintenant il s'en vont c'est
fini une partie de la récolte est vendue
au village dans ce sens des processions
interminables qui seront la yukunkoun
face à la presque à la frontière de la
Guinée du Sénégal pour vendre l'excédent
de récolte sur cette récolte est vendue
aussi à des ramasseurs si rien libanais
ce sont les gros trusts du commerce
là-bas en Guinée et un peu en porte
toute l'Afrique
de suite pesée
la bascule en voie tricher toujours un
petit peu
merci beaucoup et à la semaine prochaine
a été réalisée avec le concours de
Gilbert le challenge spécial montage
pierre raie sont Luke Perry Nice Christ
Nathalie Mireille illustration sonore de
Nice